tenemos vacío más 261 igual a 630 y los
invito a qué pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta
hay varias formas de encontrar qué valor
va aquí en este vacío vamos a
visualizarlo en una recta numérica esta
es mi recta numérica y comenzamos en
nuestro signo de interrogación que es mi
vacío y si le agregamos 261 a esto vamos
a llegar al 630
llegamos a 630
qué es este número de acá lo que
significa que si comenzamos en 630
y le restamos 261 a 630
y lo estamos viendo en sentido contrario
comenzamos en 630 y les restamos 261
menos 261 pues vamos a regresar a este
signo de interrogación a nuestro vacío
hay varias formas en las que pueden
calcular esto pero lo voy a hacer de una
forma que normalmente yo haría si
tratara de hacer esta operación en mi
mente voy a tratar de simplificar
algunas de estas cantidades y es una de
muchas formas que hay para hacer
cálculos mentales
como yo lo haría es primero restar 200
voy a quitar 200 y lo voy a dibujar más
o menos por acá aunque no es un dibujo a
escala esto es menos 200 que me va a
llevar a 430 esta resta la puedo
calcular sin problemas en mi mente
simplemente le quité 200 a esto y ahora
quiero restar 60 a esto
- 60
cuatrocientos treinta sesenta
esto es cuarenta y tres décimas menos
seis décimas y va a ser treinta y siete
décimas o trescientos setenta esto es
370 y a esto le restó una más estoy
restando 200 luego 60 y sólo me queda
restar 1
370 menos 1 pues va a ser 369
esto de aquí es 369
otra forma de resolverlo es intercambiar
el orden si vacío 261 es igual a 360
podemos decir que 261
más vacío
es igual a 630
lo único que hice fue intercambiar el
orden de aquí y podemos visualizarlo
como algo diferente en la recta numérica
de nuevo dibujamos nuestra recta
numérica
más o menos así aquí está mi recta y
puedo comenzar en 261
aquí comenzamos 261 y quiero llegar a
quiero llegar aquí y la cantidad que voy
a agregar va a ser lo que está en este
vacío que tengo que agregar a 261 para
llegar a 630 pues quiero agregar números
que sean fáciles para mí de calcular
puedo agregar un 9 aquí y llego a 270
porque le agregue 9 pues porque quedaría
así 270 que es un número entero y a esto
le puedo agregar 30 más 30 aunque bueno
esto no está muy a escala
y voy a llegar a 300
a partir de 300 pues para llegar a 630
solo tengo que sumar 330 solo 330 aquí
cuantos um en total 9 30 es 39 39 330 es
369 así que estas son dos maneras de
llegar al mismo valor dos formas de
resolver el mismo problema